TO FoxNews.com.
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK.
INSIDE THE ISSUE, SPECIAL
EDITION OF TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
UNTIL RECENTLY BRETT WEINSTEIN
WAS A BIOLOGY PROFESSOR AT
EVERGREEN STATE COLLEGE IN
OREGON.
LAST YEAR THOUGH A TARGET MOM
TARGETED HIM WHEN HE REFUSED TO
LEAVE CAMPUS BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF HIS SKIN.
HE TOOK A PRINCIPAL POSITION AS
A LIBERAL BY THE WAY.
LATER HE FELT HE HAD TO RESIGN
AND HE DID.
HE TESTIFIED TO CONGRESS ABOUT
FREE SPEECH ON CAMPUS AND AFTER
HE DID THAT, HE SPOKE WITH US.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK ON.
>> Tucker: AMAZINGLY, IT'S
BEEN A YEAR SINCE ALL OF THIS
HAPPENED.
WE TALK TO YOU IN THE MIDDLE OF
IT, WHAT ARE THE LESSONS THAT
YOU ARE TAKING FROM THE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU WENT THROUGH
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU WENT THROUG
THROUGH?
>> IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT IT
HAS BEEN A YEAR BUT IT HAS BEEN
ALMOST EXACTLY A YEAR, AND MUCH
HAS CHANGED.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT IS THAT THE
CONVERSATION IS IN A VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN IT WAS LAST
MAY.
WE ARE NOW ABLE TO DISCUSS
ISSUES OF IDENTITY POLITICS, AND
PEOPLE ARE STILL IN FLAMES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THAT DIALOGUE.
WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IN A WAY THAT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE LAST MAY.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY A RECOGNITION THAT THE
COUNTRY IS IN DANGER, AND IT IS
BEING PLACED IN DANGER BY
IDENTITY POLITICS BOTH ON THE
FAR RIGHT AND THE FAR LEFT.
SO I SEE A MOVEMENT LED IN PART
BY THE INTELLECTUAL DARK WEB AND
FIRE TOWARDS WHAT I WOULD CALL A
PATRIOTIC CENTER, WHERE PEOPLE
WHO DISAGREE OVER MANY ISSUES OF
POLICY FIND THEMSELVES ALIGNED
OVER BASIC AMERICAN PRINCIPLES.
>> Tucker: YES.
SO AS I RECALL, YOU ARE KIND OF
CAUGHT UNAWARE BY THIS, YOU ARE
ABSORBED IN YOUR ACADEMIC
DISCIPLINE.
YOU WERE KIND OF A TRADITIONAL
FREE-SPEECH LIBERAL, YOU DIDN'T
FULLY APPRECIATE WHAT HAD BEEN
HAPPENING ON CAMPUS UNTIL YOU
STOOD UP AND TOOK THE
TRADITIONALLY LIBERAL POSITION
THAT YOU SHOULDN'T ATTACK PEOPLE
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR SKIN
COLOR.
AND YOU GOT COUNTED OFF CAMPUS
AND THREATENED WITH VIOLENCE.
HAVE YOU RECONCILED WITH
EVERGREEN YOURSELF, HAVE YOU
SPOKEN TO THE PRESIDENT OR HAVE
THEY APOLOGIZE TO YOU?
WHERE DOES THAT STAND NOW?
>> THEY HAVE DONE QUITE THE
OPPOSITE OF APOLOGIZING.
THEY HAVE HIRED A P.R. TEAM THAT
QUITE OFTEN DEMONIZES MYSELF AND
MY WIFE IN THE OLYMPIAN WHICH IS
THE LOCAL PAPER.
THINGS ON CAMPUS HAVE ACTUALLY
GROWN, AS MUCH AS IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE, MUCH WORSE THAN THEY
WERE DURING THE RIOTS OF
MAY 2017.
SO EVERGREEN STATE COLLEGE HAS
TAKEN A TURN TOWARDS THE
AUTHORITARIAN THAT IS NOTHING IF
NOT BREATHTAKING.
PEOPLE ARE BEING FIRED FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO OFFER ANY SORT OF
CHALLENGE TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
THOSE WHO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ITS RECKLESS
QUEST FOR WHAT IS FALSELY CALLED
EQUITY ARE BEING PROMOTED, AND
THE COLLEGE FACES A TERRIBLE
FINANCIAL CRISIS AS A RESULT OF
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
SHOWING UP.
HAVING SEEN WHAT THE CAMPUS IS
DESCENDING INTO, PEOPLE HAVE
DECIDED TO GO ELSEWHERE TO
COLLEGE WHICH HAS PUT THE
COLLEGE $6 MILLION IN THE RED.
>> Tucker: THAT IS ALSO SAD
AND CRAZY.
SO ALL YOU DID WAS SAY, I'M NOT
GOING TO LEAVE BECAUSE I'M THE
WRONG SKIN COLOR.
I THINK THAT'S THE TRADITIONAL
CIVIL RIGHTS POSITION, AND ON
WHAT GROUNDS ARE THEY ATTACKING
YOU?
>> IRONICALLY THE CHALLENGE, THE
ONE THAT APPEARS TO RESONATE
WITH PEOPLE FROM THE FAR RIGHT
AND LEFT, AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
A THREAT PHONED IN FROM A MAN IN
NEW JERSEY WHO CLAIM TO HAVE A
GUN AND AT ANY RATE, IT WAS IN
NEW JERSEY.
BUT THE ARGUMENT IS EFFECTIVELY
THAT STANDING UP AND SPEAKING
ABOUT WHAT WAS TAKING PLACE WAS
BREAKING RANKS IN A WAY THAT
DAMAGE THE COLLEGE, BUT WHAT WAS
NEVER SAID WAS THAT, YOU INVITED
ME TO TALK TO YOU AND YOUR
AUDIENCE AT A TIME WHEN THE REST
OF THE PRESS WAS LOOKING THE
OTHER WAY, AND WHAT IS HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO APPRECIATE, WHEN I WAS
ON YOUR PROGRAM, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE COLLEGE, GEORGE BRIDGES,
HAD LITERALLY STOOD DOWN THE
POLICE FORCE SO THEY WERE UNABLE
TO INTERVENE BETWEEN WRITERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY LIKE
MYSELF.
AND THE RIOTERS TOOK UP CARRYING
BASEBALL BATS AND BATONS AND
THEY CHALLENGE PEOPLE THAT
DISAGREED WITH THEM PHYSICALLY.
IT WAS QUITE A DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
I WAS APPARENTLY BEING HUNTED
FROM CAR TO CAR BY PROTESTERS, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY HAD IN MIND
BUT, AT A TIME THAT THAT WAS
TAKING PLACE IN MY OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD, GOING ON A PROGRAM
WITH AN AUDIENCE UNDERSTOOD TO
BE RIGHT OF CENTER WAS LIKE SOME
KIND OF SIN.
>> Tucker: THAT IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
I THOUGHT THEN AND I THINK NOW,